all right many of you knew this was
coming even right wing Drudge Report is
Raising questions about Trump dementia
after a completely deranged and
outrageous speech in Wilmington North
Carolina over the weekend Drudge Report
after Trump's completely dissembled
speech saying dementing done dementing
Dawn yes this has now gone mainstream
Donald Trump holding a so-called rally
in Wilmington North Carolina over the
weekend which we covered Live on YouTube
twitch and Facebook at the rally Trump
didn't make any sense and you absolutely
have to see some of the things that took
place Donald Trump denied being a
terrorist at the event
understand that a former president is
denying being a terrorist that is not
normal in the United States two
make America great again Mega remember
what you know they say mega Magna they
don't want to say what it means it means
make America great again Uncle Sam
supporters as they want to call us
domestic terrorists you believe it I'm
not a terrorist
but you know what there's great anger in
this country right now there's great
anger in this country never forget all
of this torment persecution and
oppression is not happening because of
anything we've done wrong right Donald
Trump as usual taking no responsibility
for anything but denying that he's a
terrorist in another really weird moment
Donald Trump said we have to keep
America gay which was another one of
these bizarre glitches where you can
tell that his brain and his mouth are
struggling to connect in anything that
we would call Common Sense uh
just take a listen to this great country
remember I was going to say it's going
to use an expression we have to keep our
country gay but but it's not I mean for
some reason it's just not great anymore
oh dear God we have to keep our country
gay
in all seriousness
it used to never be okay to say the
country isn't the best remember that
during the Iraq War for example during
which I started following and covering
politics
whenever those on the left would say
this really makes the US look bad this
invasion of Iraq because of 9 11 even
though they had nothing to do with each
other after making a case with faulty
intelligence
about weapons of mass destruction it
makes the country look terrible globally
and the polls showed it and Republicans
would say no that's unpatriotic you can
never criticize this country ever ever
ever and now it's completely mainstream
for republicans in the Trump Maga world
to say the country is no longer great it
used to be totally unacceptable to say
that then Donald Trump does his n-word
thing and you can tell the CR when Trump
asks the crowd do you know what the
n-word is they get really excited the
n-word you know what the n-word is it's
no no no no
Trump going no no no before the crowd
starts yelling it out and there were a
handful of black people there that who
would have would have probably not loved
that uh but Trump has to tell the crowd
no no no no no no no no I'm talking
about a different N word n word you know
what the
you can see one one black guy over
Trump's left shoulder
sort of nodding a sigh of relief As
Trump says it's it's nuclear it's
nuclear everybody's sort of relaxed here
a very very strange moment
um and then uh Donald Trump again just
one of these things where it's not clear
whether his mind is scrambled or the
teleprompter is glitching you know
everything they do is disinformation
they say things and they keep saying I'm
saying I'm saying them as people start
even believing them or not believing
them there's not a lot of belief in this
place with all these thousands of people
going as far as the eye can see yeah
doesn't make any sense and then lastly
Donald Trump again playing the ominous
conspiracy music as he talks about how
bad things are in the country in this
particular case rambling about airports
being dirty I guess
we are a nation who has once revered
airports are dirty and a crowded mess
where you sit and wait for hours and
then are notified that the plane won't
leave and they have no idea what it will
a nation where ticket prices are through
the roof they don't have the pilots fly
the planes they don't want or seek
qualified air traffic controllers yeah
so anyway Trump knows very little about
what's going on in commercial Aviation
he's flown private for like 20 years
bonus clip bonus clip one of the
speakers before Trump
um mentioned Joe Biden and the crowd
immediately says lock him up remember
that's not due process that's not Law
and Order and
87 000 more IRS agents to treat all of
these Working Families like tax Cheats
by the way remember
55 000 of the 87 000 are to replace
retiring agents it's all really not very
scary when you know the facts come on
folks
[Music]
look
[Applause]
remember
it is not Law and Order to lock up
someone who hasn't even been charged
with a crime scary stuff and the
attendees are even scarier
the summer is over busy season is back
in full force who has time to meal prep
and cook and clean up every single day I
don't and that's why I turn to Splendid
spoon our sponsor Splendid spoon
delivers delicious Ready-to-Eat
plant-based meals right to my door I'm
not vegan but I like increasing my plant
intake and Splendid spoon is the perfect
way to do it so many different reasons
why an increasingly plant-based diet is
a great thing you can choose from over
50 meals from breakfast smoothies and
lunch bowls to Noodle dinners and light
soups so much variety vegetables legumes
healthy fats whole grains spices from
all over the world one of my absolute
favorites are the green smoothies so
much great stuff in them get started
today and get a hundred and twenty
dollars off your first three boxes at
splendidspoon.com Pacman the link is
down below